our series a more perfect union aims to
show us that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning we look at a pair of college
students who use their spring break for
a greater purpose millions of students
descend on beaches for the college
tradition but to science majors from the
University of Miami traveled to a
northern California camp
Matea via al shows us how they shared an
enthusiasm for science with a younger
generation deep in Northern California's
redwoods we met science majors neigh ha
I Faraj you and Lily Adam Palma Pia
sorry for spring break
where they've stepped out of their quiet
chemistry lab at the University of Miami
and into the noisy rainy forest looking
to inspire young campers you did find a
rifle beetle I got it the temperature
hovers around 40 degrees but the campers
don't seem to notice it was pouring
I got off so and I still have fun how
many legs does it have the kids are
learning how to identify beetles and
larvae while gaining insight into water
ecosystems now just to be very clear
this is your Spring Break
this is a nice thing yeah what are you
doing I'm in the middle of the woods and
we're I can't be have you ever count
before no and you call this an
alternative break yes
what in the world is that this is kind
of the time that we have no excuse to
say no and be fully immersed in what
we're doing here nearly 7,000 preteens
gather at Camp Campbell to study science
in the woods what do you think can get
its nose in there hummingbird many of
their families don't have the money for
camp so these trips are paid for with
ymca funds
there is this new generation of kids who
are ready to accept new ideas in a way
that I think adults sometimes struggle
with Wow I am absolutely terrified of
snags and so I I did not even think I
could do something like that honestly
but I get I know that like hey leave my
camper she was scared as well and I knew
that if I did it like she would do it so
like I have to do it for her the
redwoods are new ground for 22 year old
Lily originally from Ghana back in Ghana
you know like my uncle lives right next
door my grandmother was like across the
street her parents left behind the
comforts of a close-knit family with the
hope of finding a better life for Lily
and her sister in America than Ghana
it's very much a male-dominated society
and so I think being here I have sort of
like owned what it is to be a woman I
know that the experiences that I have
here and not the same experiences I
would have had back there when you
started to do these alternative breaks
what were you taking away from them
the world is like so much bigger than
myself I've been exposed to communities
that I honestly would have never been
exposed to if I hadn't gotten outside
that comfort zone I've learned that you
have to care about people and you can't
care about people if you don't know the
people out there what they're going
through
exactly
at science camp every activity teaches
about the natural world
there's even a song about the droppings
bears leave behind I mean they just
always attack every day with such great
enthusiasm and that really sort of
inspires me as well because even if I'm
like exhausted and they want to sing a
camp song and you know you can't do
their enthusiasm for science has both
Lilly and Neha on the road to becoming
pediatricians and they agree that giving
up their spring break to give back to
kids will have a lasting impact it's
just something that you can't explain
when you're working with kids there's
like an innocence and a I don't know I
don't even know how to explain it
you came yeah it might be the other way
around yeah definitely receive yes this
morning media vol Boulder Creek
California all right mother yet it's
just a win-win for everybody
all the way around everybody gets
something out of it it's great let's
discuss when did college students start
looking like they're 10 does that mean
we're just getting old and getting older
that was really great really great